who survived the battle for home tree is
Jake now the leader of the navi people
we break down the ending of Avatar
before the way of water premieres Avatar
takes place in 2154 humans have depleted
the Earth's natural resources and moved
on to outer space colonizing worlds like
Pandora a moon orbiting a gas giant in
the Alpha Centauri Galaxy the main
character is Jake Sully a paraplegic
former Marine his identical twin brother
was part of a team of scientists on
Pandora who are researching the planet
and its indigenous inhabitants the navi
using human Navi hybrids called avatars
humans can walk among the navi
communicate with them and learn their
ways Jake joins Dr Grace Augustine
scientist Norm Spellman and Marine pilot
Trudy on their research mission of
course the resources development
Administration has more in mind as RDA
administrator Parker Selfridge points
out the real reason humans are on
Pandora is to mine a mineral called
unobtainium which sells for Millions on
Earth Colonel Miles quarrich offers make
a deal find out all he can about the
navi and he'll make sure Jake gets new
legs but Jake's infiltration into the
navi civilization doesn't go as he
expected he meets a navi woman named
natiri learns about the planet and the
navi spiritual connection to all living
things and becomes one of them Jake and
natiri fall in love and become life
mates Complicated by the fact that Jake
is still a human living vicariously
through his Navi Avatar and the fact
that he's technically a spy for the RDA
I trusted you you trust me now please
toward the end of Avatar the RDA orders
the destruction of Home tree natiri's
tribe's home base because of the rich
deposits of unobtainium that Lies
Beneath by this point Jake is fully on
team Navi even though natiri and other
members of her tribe have turned against
him after finding out about his spying
Jake has completely changed his identity
considering himself a part of the navi
embracing their beliefs and so he fights
for their cause against the RDA but
quarrette's huge military planes massive
guns and numerous soldiers quickly
overpower the tribe and Tom tree is
destroyed during the battle many lives
are lost including natiri's father a
toucan Jake Grace and Norm's human
bodies are rescued by Trudy who airlifts
them and their Avatar capsules to a safe
location while their Navi avatars are
left in the forest but during the Mayhem
quarridge shoots them with a bullet
hitting Grace to regain the trust of
natiri the Oma Takaya tribe and their
new Chief zute Jake mounts and bonds
with taruk a huge dragon-like Beast
related to the smaller banshees by
bonding with this Fierce Beast who the
navi both Revere and fear Jake proves
that he's a part of the navi that he
respects their culture and he wants to
live among them Jake is embraced by
natiri her mother moat and zute and
together they make plans to gather the
numerous Navi tribes to fight back
against the RDA and evict them from
Pandora before Jake sets out to unite
the navi Clans he has one request of
moat save Grace still suffering from her
gunshot wound Grace's life is in the
Navy's hands as is the life of her
Avatar as natiri explains all life on
Pandora is connected via a biological
neural network though the navi consider
it more of a spiritual connection than a
scientific one the tree of voices allows
a living Navi to hear the memories of
their ancestors while the Tree of Souls
is said to be the closest connection to
AWA the guiding force of Pandora that
the navi worship as a deity the Tree of
Souls natiri explains has such power
that it can transfer her Consciousness
through the immersive neural network of
Pandora and have her permanently placed
into her Avatar body so she can survive
this transformation doesn't just tie
like the Navy's spiritual beliefs but
also hints at the potential scientific
advancements that could be achieved in
the future Grace's body is weak and she
doesn't survive the process but before
she dies she assures Jake that she sees
AWA the connections are real and the
world of Pandora is truly a living thing
[Music]
she's real
the final battle for Pandora includes
the RDA Soldiers the many tribes of
Pandora and one final participant AWA
herself or at least AWA manifested
through the animals and wildlife of
Pandora who came to the Navy's defense
at the last minute the night before the
battle Jake connects neurologically to
the Tree of Souls and asks that AWA
helped them on their quest to defeat the
RDA this more than his bond with taruk
proves Jake has fully embraced his life
as a navi he used taruk to regain natiri
and the other Navy's trust but his
prayer to AWA is a private act showing
us that he now believes in the power of
Pandora and its spiritual Network during
the battle at a moment when it looks
like the navi might be defeated once
again suddenly a great Rumble is heard
from Beyond the Forest numerous animals
from throughout the planet join the
fight understanding that the RDA is
destroying their world and their
survival depends on their involvement
not only is the neural connection on
Pandora more significant than previously
thought but the creatures of the planet
are capable of more complex decisions
it was heard you the animals joining the
fight eventually lead to the rda's
defeat and the return of Pandora to its
original inhabitants after the battle
many of the humans left on Pandora are
forced to head back to Earth Jake of
course wants to stay but he can't do so
well still in his human body the love
between Jake and natiri is strong but
with humans unable to breathe Pandora's
air maintaining their relationship would
be rather difficult not to mention the
fact that Jake doesn't even consider
himself human anymore he spent so much
time as one of the navi learning and
embracing their way of life that
remaining human would just be a letdown
so Jake asks the navi to connect his
human body as well as his Navi Avatar to
the Tree of Souls via their neural
networks the navi pray together chant
and ask that Ewa transfer Jake from his
human form into his Avatar the closing
shot of the film is Jake's Avatar
opening his eyes urgently suggesting
that the process did indeed work and
that Jake can now go on living as a true
Navi Sigourney Weaver's Dr Grace
Augustine doesn't survive the Battle of
Home tree and she was far from the only
casualty during the Epic final Conflict
Trudy switches sides as well outfitting
her fighter plane and face with Navi
colors but her plane gets shot down
omatakai achieved sute is also mortally
wounded in the battle and after the
battle ends asks Jake to end his
suffering at first Jake is reluctant to
do so but as sute explains it is a great
honor and passes the tribe leadership
onto Jake before Jake ends his suffering
on the human front scientist Norm
Spellman survives the battle
unfortunately his Navi Avatar gets shot
and dies so Norm has to remain in his
human form on Pandora from then on Norm
is one of the few humans who is
permitted to stay and he fronts a new
and ongoing scientific exploration team
one that has nothing to do with
procuring unobtainium or Conquering the
indigenous peoples of the planet
natiri's mother moat also survives the
final battle and it's she who supervises
the ritual at the Tree of Souls to
transfer Jake's Consciousness from his
human body to his Navi Avatar greedy RDA
administrator Parker Selfridge was only
out for one thing the money and power
that came with dominating the navi and
destroying their land as a character
Selfridge was the movie's embodiment of
colonialist and imperialist capitalist
interests his descriptions of the navi
as quote fly bitten Savages that live in
trees could mirror any of History's
conquering forces as they dominated the
indigenous peoples in various countries
across the world thankfully Selfridge is
banished from Pandora by the end of the
film though it isn't known whether he's
learned any kind of lesson a much more
gruesome fate befalls Colonel Miles
quarridge who throughout the movie
becomes a more Sinister violent and
frightening villain than Selfridge
during the final battle quarridge heads
to the Hallelujah mountains where Jake's
human body is connected to his Navi
Avatar through the Pod quarrych tries to
disconnect and kill Jake but his mission
is interrupted by natiri writing her new
Santa tour a fierce land mammal of
Pandora that looks like a cross between
a cat and a dinosaur just as quarrette
is about to crush Jake with the use of
his amp suit natiri launches two giant
arrows into his chest it's after
quarrych's death that natiri meets
Jake's human form for the first time
lovingly greeting each other with the
traditional Navi saying I see you
I see you
Avatar was so successful and James
Cameron became so immersed in its World
building that it's no surprise there are
plans for a whopping four additional
movies but with or without all of the
upcoming sequels James Cameron's Avatar
was a truly Innovative and interesting
film one that plunged audiences deep
into a new world and heralded a new era
of filmmaking the motion capture
technology as well as the use of 3D
definitely had an impact on the film
industry although 3D as a gimmick is
dying down a bit these days motion
capture as well as new advances in
computer graphics and life-like
animation are more integral to
filmmakers than ever it's those
technological advancements that will be
the lasting Legacy of Avatar as well as
Cameron's ability to bring action and
heart to some of his most elaborate
worlds regardless of how the sequels
fare the original ushered us into the
New Millennium of cinematic experiences
so it's exciting to imagine what's
coming next from Cameron and Pandora
when the second avatar movie The Way of
water debuts in December 2022
foreign